foreign
welcome to the 95th Academy Awards
visual effects Bake Off congratulations
to everyone quite an accomplishment
we saw in the Reel that yellow smoke and
the tanks coming out of that can you
talk a little bit about the way that
became your creature and the way you
were kind of tuning that performance to
get as much character out of that as
possible the Yellow Smoke was something
that we wanted to keep open for the
audience to figure out what this is I
mean it could be a gas attack at the
same time I always thought of it as sort
of announcement of the creatures whether
it's their smell or their pollution when
you see a big cloud wave coming you know
there's something bad behind it
that sequence was so sensitive to
contrast whether you see him or not so
we actually had to render those shots
twice one pass with the machines and
then one without and we sort of
integrating did a life mixing in DaVinci
Resolve which was really fun to do
[Music]
the city streets are crowded for the
holiday
even with the rain
filmmakers saw Gotham as a character in
the movie and to create that archetypal
City at the height of its Decay we shot
plates in a half dozen cities and then
we heavily altered and extended the
photography our characters wore black
leather and most of the sets were wet
and very dark if we shot in a
traditional blue screen stage blue spill
would have contaminated everything so we
created a pop-up LED volume and we were
able to light everything using real-time
3D backgrounds of the city that we
created during prep Jesus this is about
a king
the Batmobile Chase was grounded in
Practical photography and physical
effects rigs the special effects
Department build for bespoke high
performance Batmobiles and each version
of the vehicle was engineered and
constructed for a specific purpose and
they were all built from scratch and
that was one of the things that because
each Batmobile was kind of custom
tailored for a specific job they didn't
all fit the design spec exactly like for
example the jumping Batmobile once it
hit the ground and it stood back up on
that long throw suspension you know it
looked like the Daddy Long Legs version
of the Batmobile and and so Anders at a
certain point had to take over and you
know replace that along with the wet
ground and fire reflecting off the water
foreign
if not more of our sets did have a water
feature of some kind so not completely
always submers but there was water
involved pretty much all the time
oh like Craig kind of chat to the
integration between Dan sudix massive
Rigs and then the islands working
combining those two worlds Yeah dance
Riggs gave us a foundation that was
absolutely Rock Steady everything
possible that was safe is basically what
we got but safe is not what you want so
you know everything needed augmentation
a layer on top basically the whole front
layer of it there was a desire overall
not just with Autumn but all of the hods
to carry on their Visions through into
post so we did lots of exploration early
on with hair makeup and costume
each one had to be treated differently
there's some costumes that would move in
a certain way so there's a bit of tuning
with that and setting different weights
digitally within it but just making sure
that we got a nice flow to it and each
one performed the way we liked
and our story called us to revive the
legendary F-14 Tomcat we chose to film
actors within an Airborne F-18 and
replace certain components digitally
this approach provided all the benefits
of cinematographer Claudio Miranda's
distinctive in cockpit photography such
as small aperture Reflections and
g-forces even though this particular
aircraft was retired in 2006. jets
flying through the air really really
quick make it really hard to figure out
a camera track and so we had to utilize
GPS data from the actual camera planes
in combination with USGS topographical
data to actually plot out various points
and then rework our light rigs to be
able to actually properly coordinate
things as Jets moving as fast as they do
actually hit curvature that changes
Lighting in extremely subtle ways
the shots were spiders helping to pull
them the navi onto the rocks it looks
complicated uh yeah as I was describing
the Reel we did it in multiple passes
and one sort of trick that we had at the
real-time depth system that we evolved
for the camera actually served us very
well in those shots because we could get
a moving mesh per frame of all the
characters and the water which we
weren't expecting to work but it did so
that uh gave us for any time we were
integrating with spider we could
generate a mesh to get contact points
I'd love to hear you talk a little bit
about how you've got the new hedrig and
the neural network and how that all
worked and well we switched to a stereo
head rig we had been using on the first
film a single camera but the cameras
were lightweight enough that we could go
with stereo but really the key because
this is such a character-driven film was
the facial system so we put everything
into a neural network and the beauty of
that is when you're changing from pose
to pose every point on the face
understands what every other point on
the face should be doing and so you get
this natural movement across the face as
you go from shape to shape
thank you very much and congratulations
again to our shortlisted films